now to an outpouring of support at the
end of Hanukkah as we learn more about
the man accused of stabbing five people
at a rabbis home in Muncie New York
hundreds gathered last night a nearby
West Nyack to pray for the victims
Grafton Thomas was charged with hate
crimes yesterday investigators say they
found his handwritten journals with
anti-semitic writings Tom Hansen is in
Muncie about 30 miles north of New York
City Tom what else do we know about the
suspect good morning well Grafton
Thomas's attorney says his client is a
former US Marine and he says he doesn't
believe that anti-semitism led to this
brutal attack meanwhile investigators
say they found in the 37 year olds
journals references to Hitler and Nazi
culture he needs serious psychiatric
evaluation and that is the primary focus
Grafton Thomas is attorney Michael
Sussman said Monday his client is not a
domestic terrorist but instead has a
history of mental illness including
auditory hallucinations it may be that
he was non-compliant with medications
according to a new criminal complaint
police found an apparent reference in
Thomas's journals to the black Hebrew
Israelite movement a group sometimes
associated with anti-semitism they also
found drawings of the Star of David and
a swastika and say Thomas made recent
internet searches such as why did Hitler
hate the Jews police say Thomas barged
into a rabbis home in Muncie New York
Saturday and said in part no one is
leaving dozens of Orthodox Jews were
inside celebrating the seventh night of
Hanukkah new surveillance video shows
Thomas in a New York City deli around
two hours after the attack he was then
apprehended by police who say he
appeared to have blood on his clothes
and hands investigators allegedly
recovered a machete in Thomas's car
which they say also appeared to have
dried blood on it this has been a shock
a total shock Reverend Wendy Paige is
the Thomas family's pastor he's always
been a gentle giant with mental illness
that one victim is still in critical
condition he has a skull fracture
Senator Chuck Schumer the senator from
New York yesterday announced a plan to
try to combat anti-semitism and Thomas
those charges that he's still facing
that are federal charges carry up to a
maximum of life in prison
David Tom thank you
you